All right, next question, I'm taking I have erected an embendazole. Passing what I think is parasites this person sent me pictures to while doing during this, having lots of ramping.
Is there a binder I need to take or is there a protocol I'm doing in taking care of detoxing all of this.
So if you're if you are passing parasites due to taking I have erected an embendazole, you don't need a binder, you won't absorb those things.
So a binder is in terms of a nutritional a nutritional binder that this person is talking about is something that will grab onto stuff in the cold.
So it's a supplement that you take like activated charcoal or some sodium alginate bentonite clay.
These are all different binders that will just grab onto things in the got typically binders by definition, you don't absorb them, they stay in the got grabs onto things that the doctor just holds on to them so that you don't reabsorb things.
You're killing parasites, you don't need to worry about that you won't reabsorb parasite wasn't to absorb any how so it was a living organism and you're killing it in toxins and don't every organism. So no, you don't need to do that, you don't really need any other help detoxing.
The only thing that I would say is go back to my seven days in detox book if you're constipated or something like that, that could be an issue you want to help with that, but no, you don't need anything like that.
So that is a good thing, I would say though with the picture that you set me I would pulse these two things if it was me meeting that I would take a break for a while, maybe go off a week and then go back on go week by week.
So understand that concept everybody and we do have an article pretty sure about what that means when I say the word pulse so when you pulse a supplement, you are
giving it a break so pulse or pulsing supplements would be going like let's say you've been taking something daily for a period of time and there can be a good idea of taking a break like dropping it down to
you know taking a weekend off so you're on five days on and then two days on that there's nothing wrong with doing that.
There's nothing wrong with, especially with like hyperbacterial, it's all going off a week and going back on again just giving your body a little bit of a break to kind of reset.
That's what pulsing supplements, pulsing, you wouldn't do that with the prescription medication, but you could do that with something that you're taking for more supplemental and hyperbacterial, but that is all followed back.